how do you identify an important result
in science and how they die and when did
I recognize that we had done it this is
not easy because in scientific research
you don't know immediately if something
is correct or not
especially when it's new and unexpected
is a big breakthroughs are unexpected
and usually draw a lot of criticism from
others so this is and it may take
several years until others have been
able to repeat the experiments and
confirm that you are right this is
usually the vehicles if the if so method
is shown not to be reproducible then one
is usually in trouble not always but
usually so when we got the first
structure soft
I actually went skiing for two years how
your social we had it that I went I went
back to teaching ski